Okay.
Hi. We should be back
So, it is
currently 100
p.m. I should have
roughly almost 5
hours to just hammer
on all these different M's and baselines
uh and experiments. I think that the
major goal right now is going to be to
get all or as many as possible of the Ms
to have a single score metric that is
normalized from 0 to one. Um to get
reasonable defaults for all the
different M's so that we can then with
one script run all the M's
uh and
get scores out of one on one plot.
and then even get a combined plot. So
that will give us a very robust
comparison
uh between these ms and other stuff.
That's going to be the goal. Welcome
YouTube folks. Welcome Twitch folks. So
should just be some chill dev, some
chill
experimenting. And uh yeah, this should
put us in a pretty good spot for
tomorrow. Um because if we get all this
done then I will be very well set up to
do either experiment side stuff or like
new algorithm stuff. Usually I try to
make Saturday like a long like deep dive
algorithm day or whatever or deep dive
edge day. So this should set us up
pretty well for that. Um because there
is one bug right now that I'm pretty
sure exists in the experience buffer uh
that we're going to have to fix before
we can do a ton of new stuff and this
should help with that.
Okay, so let's get started with
it. I believe we have Enduro working.
Yes, this has normalized score. Uh the
one thing that I would like to do if I
could is reorder these so that they show
up in a better
order. Do you think reinforcement
learning will be as much useful
efficient like other machine learning
techniques or can it surpass them a
different use cases for things? I think
it is very very likely that
reinforcement learning is going to be
essential for long-term AI progress.
Recent use of RL even on LLMs would
suggest I'm right on that. Uh the thing
that is yet to be determined is uh
whether we will need like RL of the type
that I'm doing completely separate from
LLMs. I still think it is very likely
that we will. And even if I'm wrong
there, I think that the type of work I'm
doing now is a really really effective
way to develop new general purpose RL
techniques. Um, like I can basically do
experiments here that would otherwise
require a thousandx the compute because
of how fast everything is. It's also
really a great way to just get open
source involvement, right? It's really
easy for people to get involved with
Puffer doing it this
Um, it goes it goes like this, right?
So, what do we think? Probably
normalized four is the most important
metric. We do like maybe
this normalized score return
length. I think that's good.
cleanly. Pong doesn't report stats very
frequently though. That's the other
thing I want to do is I want to change
it so we get like consistent
printouts. I don't think I have to
change anything on the M side for that
though. I think that that's just I have
to make it so that when you get stats to
the dashboard, they continue in place
there. Okay. Normalize force for return
length and then this N at the
bottom doesn't super matter,
right? I could technically just make it
so that you have to have all these
attributes, right?
this. I think we'll think about that
after though. I think we'll do it this
way first. We'll manually define all
these different things and then uh later
we'll see whether it makes sense to have
like a default log that just does all
this for you. But I think that this will
be good for now.
So I think that the only thing that'll
be a little tricky with what I'm doing
right now, uh, there are a few
environments where it's kind of tough to
think of a normalized score metric.
Other than that, this should be pretty
straightforward. So plan is just to jam
on this. This will probably take me an
hour or two uh, to get all the M's the
way I like them. So happy to answer
random RL questions and stuff. In the
meantime, we're really trying to start
scaling to more contributors as well. Um
I'm looking into acquiring much more
hardware for essentially to give
contributors access to like real
training compute. Um but I do have to
wait for the tariff prices to come down
a little bit
first because the machines are expensive
right now.
Way too many metrics in Enduro. I'd say
I'll chat with like the authors of all
these ends about like which metrics are
actually
useful. There is such a thing as too
many
metrics. When you have stuff that's not
useful, it's uh if you have a metric
that you basically there's no point in
ever looking at, you're better off not
having it is what I would say.
Um, does it make sense to call it
normalized score when it's not always
going to
be? Because some of these things like
this one, right? This score metric is
not actually what we're normalizing,
right? The actual metric that matters is
um like days completed or whatever.
this? It's a little misleading, right,
to call it normalized score if it's not
actually based on the score
what? Let's see if dumb LLM can come up
with random
thing. I have
an score in
RLM. I want to
define 01
normaliz often but not always.
performance or just
perf. I think that's better, right? Just
call it perf.
I try not to spend too long on naming
things,
but sometimes it's useful.
Okay, that will break if you make that
an int.
lives. So we do
uh
perfect. I'm thinking what the hard
environments are going to be for this. A
lot of the ones that don't have like
clean score have um win rate or
something that we can use instead.
There are a few like ourware I guess
where it's a little
So they should now have
per
perfect. Yeah. So we can actually make
it so score doesn't have to be uh a
mandatory variable, right? We can make
it so like if it's win rate, it can just
be win rate or
whatever. But we still need two metrics,
right? Because one has to be
Yeah, that's fine.
So blaster
breakout fix
car. This does not have a binding
function.
So,
uh, I guess not all of them are bound
yet,
Even stuff as simple as like partful can
be really useful frankly like it's just
like a classic task and now we have it.
So you know thanks bet for
that. Ah so this here is not okay. I
forgot that I actually do have to
adjust if if we have Syon, I actually do
have to adjust
Syon will pick up changes and just redo
for us. That's
nice. Perf score return and length.
Perfect.
N. Think that does
it. We have to add this to
us. We are getting rid of
Syon but that is working on that.
The new binding system is like way
easier than
Syon. I don't hate Syon. It's like nice
for what it is,
but we kind of just have better
now. I forgot to do anything with perk,
didn't I?
Wait,
what?
Uh oh.
right? Kind of
does actually.
are. So now per is a different
number and we'll go
up to
So then technically not everything has
to have score right it can have a
different
That would be
good. Okay.
Um, any of these other ones? I think
Pong would potentially have screwed this
up, right?
Yeah. Okay. So, I'm a little concerned
with
punk because I think uh per is probably
going to be screwy
here.
Score. Yeah, this can be negative,
right?
something like this,
right? And then this will give you
percentage of points one.
long is just really long games. I guess
takes a while to
So, this should hit
one. We're close to one. Yeah, there it
is. That's
one. So, breakouts work. Um,
Blastar, I think Blastar works. Last bet
on that one. Purple
works. Purple
So, connect four, we just fixed
uh
CPR. I haven't really played with this
end yet. We got this one submitted in a
PR relatively
How many agents is it
per? Is it like three agents per or
something
right? So, eight agents. We want
uh 4096 total. So, we want 2048 in here.
Uh, so divide by 4 is 256, I
believe. Oh, but they put 12 agents in
here. Is there a reason it needs to be
12? 12 is an awkward number. Can I just
do
eight? Okay. What's
wrong? Seed.
Easy. Okay. So, this gets score and
moves or
whatever. We'll just check source.
Okay. So then this
is n logs of
work. Yeah, this is absolutely not how
logging should work.
screwy. This is a cool end though. So, I
would like to have this working.
Oh, here it is. The agents. No, this is
fine. We just have to They're just using
the log buffer wrong. Okay, that's
totally fine. That's a lot easier than
what I
thought. It is allocated correctly. It's
just getting used wrong. So, this is
reset. Reset logs. That's fine.
Uh reward agents
That's crazy that he got a seating issue
with the card.
I guess the end doesn't reset or
whatever. Oh, so he gives it reward when
uh the agent gets
food
because cuz the end never resets,
right? Okay, hang on. That is
because I can define a score and a
reward with that. But how do we define
perf? It's the same problem as Rword,
right?
You want like minimum time to get food,
but it's um
That's slightly
obnoxious. I guess if we look at all the
ends that we have,
right? So, blaster these ones you can
just normalize reward go is win rate.
Grid is win rate. Mo is win rate. Neural
MMO 3 has a rough max score. Hong has a
max score. This one's not done. This
one's not done. Owware is the same
problem as this
one. Uh,
Snake. Snake's kind of hard, but we can
kind of just arbitrarily define a max
score. Squared as a max score. This
one's not done. This one's not done.
This one has the win
rate. Uh, this one has the exact same
problem and this one has So, okay. So,
the only one that we have, we have three
problem M's and they all have the issue
that the reward is
basically go get the thing and how well
you're doing is how quickly do you get
the
thing, right?
that? I mean, one thing we could do is
just like
estimate a minimum
time. That's not
amazing. That would be the punt though,
right? Is we just like guess a minimum
amount of time.
instance? You really don't know what the
max score is, right?
I think we punt on it for now. We just
like pick them. We just pick
one. Okay. So, they were actually
correct then in these the way that
they're logging here.
So
um then we
do add
log and then this is also what add log
be I guess one over the episode length
is the really easy one, right?
But that's going to be like a stupidly
no low
I could do it that way for now. To be
honest,
I don't like it that way
though. What is a good score function?
Damn it.
It could just be one minus a fraction of
the episode length. That's better, isn't
it?
Yeah, that's pretty good. That'll like
produce a reasonable curve, I
think. Let me try
this. And uh we have to collect. Let's
have Syon,
Okay. And then this actually gets worse
over time, but it's because of uh the M
dynamics. Well, I think this will work
generally and this should produce
something clean for like hardware and
other
stuff. Uh did we do go? I don't think we
did go yet correctly. We were really
close to doing go.
Yeah. So, this wants we want to put
this
here. Don't need win rate.
things.
Yep. It's this
This is kind of just doing
like environment janitor work, but it's
chill. And this actually like
meaningfully improves the uh usability
of puffer as
well. So, it's quite good.
on. Well, we know it isn't winning
though, right?
30% of
games. Oh, did go kind of just start
working. Yes, it
did.
Cool. Good to know.
to we have episode return episode
length. We need
victory. We'll do this in towers alive
or
whatever. And this is still Syon, I
believe.
So, this is going to need to have purple
and score
Oh, [ __ ] You put it in the wrong
one. Go here.
one. This should be good. This should be
very good.
It does annoy me that it takes so long
to log, but it takes a while to finish
the games, I
believe.
Yep. So, here you
are. That is win rate.
This tower is
alive and then episode return uh not
being anything is kind of
Confused how
this does stuff.
Okay. Well, this will be part of the
binding change, I assume. We'll uh we'll
leave it like this for
now. Don't want to spend too much time
on any one
favorite still has old. Oh, it has new
login. We already I already did that.
Okay. So, this needs
divided
by Is there a max
levels. So, we'll do float and levels
like this.
And we're not even really going to be
able to see this do much of anything
because
um it uh takes forever to
train because it's
hard. But we should at least be able to
see our logs.
correct. Oh, lovely. We don't get uh
agent steps
now. Uh so we want two
ends. I should probably put a
note in fifth for now because of
Okay. So score shouldn't be one. Oh no,
it should be
one. Yeah, that's
fine because min com prop is going to be
one and this will be
0.025. We're good with that.
So that's neural m3. We already did
pong. Roboc's not done. Rocket lender is
not done.
Rareware. This has return
length curves.
So this will work.
Hopefully there'll be
something. And we also need to modify
Syon real quick.
uh curve could be
already already good. So that's bad.
agent. I just have to figure out where
the delivery code is.
are. Should be something like this,
maybe.
I actually think we will end up doing
something with this end because if we
were to like jazz this up a little bit,
we could probably make like a decent
warehouse type simulator.
Okay. So this is not logging the score
correctly.
reasonable
snake. What's our current
snake? This just has return length and
score. So, we'll do Oh, I guess I
haven't updated my snake that because
that was going to do
that. So, we'll just do this one for
now.
score I can actually just
do over 150. Was it min
one? Was it 1.0?
um like return over length or something
or score divide by length.
I wonder if this starts going down over
time because
like when the snakes get longer, do they
just live for longer but not get any
food. I don't
know. We'll leave it like this for now.
And I guess we'll find out, won't
we? Good first approximation at
least. I would like it if it were a
higher metric by default,
but guess this is fine.
Uh, this also doesn't have
per float
per it's going to be the same as
This is just got to be like a
conditional.
I'll uh I'll be back in a few minutes. I
got to go check on something with the
network.